non solo un professore né studioso
neanche un artista sono semplice
cittadino un infermiere
io vorrei cercherei di raccontarvi come
che sono diventato un semplice cittadino
un infermiere
sono nato in eritrea in asmara nel 1980
ho avuto un'infanzia una delle scienza
molto tranquilla grazie ai miei genitori
la situazione che c'era in rete mi sono
diplomato in una scuola scientifica
ho vissuto fino a 18 anni nel 1998
l'eritrea entrò in guerra contro il
paese confinante litio che
apparentemente per un motivo di confine
io in re 3 a quel momento ci fu la
chiamata obbligatoria per tutti i
giovani che hanno compiuto 18 anni sia
uomini che donne a fare il servizio
militare
un tempo indeterminato
io e miei compagni di classe siamo
destinati a fare il militare
quel momento e l'eritrea e liceo piano
avevano un conflitto di fuoco dove
morivano circa 80 mila ragazzi io ho
partecipato
la guerra
dove ho aperto tanti miei amici e
parenti
ai miei compagni la guerra finisce nel
io ho vissuto poi quella speranza che di
tornare a casa
purtroppo svanì questo speranza subito
perché l'eritrea e l'etiopia entravano
in una guerra fredda che dura ancora in
corsa che durò 14 anni
io ho vissuto questa vita dopoguerra
quello di aspettando che il nemico che
viene in un deserto sperduto come nel
libro il deserto dei tartari e dopo tre
anni non ce l'ho più fatta ho deciso di
scappare
questi sono alcuni dei miei amici di
scuola gli amici di militari che c'erano
con e ho deciso di scappare dal re 3 a
attraversando e vari i confini
rischiando sia di perdere la mia vita
più volte ho superato il confine
dell'eritrea passando dai militari che
vivono nel confine attraversato il
deserto che c'è tra il sudan e libia
impiegando più di 20 giorni infine ho
attraversato anche il mare che separa
all'africa dal dall'europa
fortunatamente sono arrivato vivo dico
fortunatamente perché come sapete sono
rimaste tante persone di una volta che
sono arrivato a lampedusa ho vissuto lì
cinque giorni in centro è dargli
sono stato trasferito in un centro di
accoglienza catanissetta dove ho fatto
la richiesta di asilo politico
na li con un documento i lavoratori del
centro di accoglienza ci hanno
accompagnato alla stazione di treno dove
era destinato verso il nord
io siccome non conoscevo nessuno in
italia non aver né amici né parenti
ho sentito parlare di roma dove si può
bene o male si può trovare dove dormire
cosa mangiare ho deciso di andare a roma
a roma
mi ricorda la prima notte quando sono
arrivato era tramite un ragazzo che è
passato prima di noi ci ha accompagnato
un capannone di 33 in italia che ha
abbandonato
ho vissuto lì per due settimane mi
ricordo questa notte la prima notte dove
sono andata a raccogliere il cartone per
dormire lì la mia fortuna sono rimasto
lì sole due settimane dai li ho deciso
di tornare qua giù in sicilia per le
motivi burocratiche per i documenti dove
sono stato accolto i miei amici da un
prete molto vicino agli stranieri a
catene setta lì siamo rimasti per due
settimane per scusate per due mesi e da
lì questo prete tramite altre
associazioni hanno messo in contatto con
un progetto qui a catania un progetto di
accoglienza sono entrato qua in progetto
di accoglienza dove ho trovato una volta
che trovato un posto dove dormire
un posto non devo più pensare a cosa
cercare per la mangiare lì ho iniziato a
pensare come riprendere la mia vita
perduta
qualche anno prima
ho iniziato a uscire da casa a studiare
la lingua italiana
a lavorare e cercare di lavoro se anche
non era facile perché una nuova cultura
integrarsi nuova lingua completamente
tutto nuovo ho iniziato grazie anche gli
operatrice del centro che mi hanno
indirizzato la strada è giusta ho
iniziato a studiare come la scuola
italiana e poi la scuola media
purtroppo siccome diploma il diploma che
aveva fatto in eritrea meno e ha
riconosciuto qui in italia ho dovuto
riprendere la scuola della scuola media
da lì ho iniziato a studiare a mano a
mano che lavoravo di giorno che avevo
iniziato a lavoricchiare stando fermo
davanti il benzinaio di tante le persone
per ricevere qualche mangia una volta
che è iniziato conoscere la città
ho iniziato a lavorava i lavori come
consegnavo le bizze della pubblicità
la variati camerieri e via via la sera
un frattempo studiavo sono una volta che
prese la scuola media sono andato alla
scuola superiore è qui vicino
mi sono diplomato come geometra da lì ho
capito che non bastava prendere solo il
diploma
ho cercato l'avventura quello di entrare
università con la mia grande che me
l'aspettavo sono riuscito a entrare
università con la facoltà di scienze
infermieristiche e ho studiato veramente
molto pesante tanto perché lavorare
studiare durante il giorno a lavorare la
sera e fine settimana e non era facile
poi grazie anche alla mia compagna che
mi aiutate durante lo studio e sono
riuscito a laurearmi in tre anni
dopodiché ho iniziato in vari ho
iniziato varie cliniche si trovano a
roma è una delle mie esperienze più
belle che ho avuto
durante questo lavoro è quello di
lavorare con medici senza frontiere a
lampedusa
ho lavorato lì per quattro mesi li ho
cercato quello di dare la mia
professionalità la mia esperienza di
vita per dare un minimo di speranza per
queste persone che arrivano come me
niente in mano con tanta speranza
li ho dato
penso e spero tutto quello che potevo e
poi spero che questa la mia storia è in
breve che vi ho raccontato non diventi
non resti un eccezione ma diventi una
regola per tutte le persone che arrivano
grazie
abbiamo sentito la storia di alì alì è
partito al suo paese è riuscito ad
arrivare è riuscito a studiare è
riuscito a realizzarsi sul lavoro e
nella famiglia ma oggi la storia di alì
è un'eccezione
proprio perché come lui tanti altri
cercano di arrivare in europa ma
purtroppo non riescono a lì è
un'eccezione perché ali è riuscito a
rimanere in vita perché pensate ali lo
chiamiamo per nome
in realtà quello che noi siamo abituati
a vedere sono i numeri
questo 110.000 è un numero che già in
questo momento è vecchio perché aumenta
ora dopo ora 110 mila e il numero delle
persone che sono sbarcate in sicilia
dall 1 gennaio del 2014
pensate io lo chiamate persone non
conosco chiaramente i loro nomi ma siamo
abituati a sentire chiamare con nomi
sbagliati o solo migranti quasi non
fossero persone quando non clandestini o
illegali come se l'essere umano fosse di
per sé illegale si tratta di donne gli
uomini di bambini che scappano da paesi
dove non riescono a condurre una vita
dignitosa
scappano da paesi dove ci sono delle
guerre scappano da paesi dove non
possono vivere la loro vita in
condizioni di libertà dove non possono
esercitare le libertà fondamentali
il loro credo non possono vivere in
maniera serena e pubblica loro
sessualità scappano da paesi colpiti dai
cambiamenti climatici e quindi diventate
invivibili
sono giovani forti sani
molto spesso sono le migliori eccellenze
dei loro prezzi dai loro paesi che
cercano un futuro migliore fanno
un percorso lungo molto duro a rischio
delle loro vite e il numero sicuramente
che vi ho detto prima sarebbe molto più
ampio se unissimo tutti i numeri di
coloro i quali non sono riusciti ad
arrivare
arrivano nella nostra regione una
regione di accoglienza arrivano a
palermo arriva un'augusta catania
messina a pozzallo a porto empedocle a
trapani a lampedusa si trovano lì
trovano in questo momento si le autorità
civili le autorità sanitarie ma trovano
migliaia di volontari anche loro delle
eccezioni delle eccezioni perché al
giorno finito il lavoro finito lo studio
tolgono la giacca tolgono il tailleur
colgono il camice la toga e mette una
divisa di giorno di notte stanno sul
molo e cercano di garantire alle persone
che arrivano in italia quanto meno i
primi diritti la tutela della salute
il check up medico è la prima cosa che
viene fatta sia a bordo delle navi che a
terra perché la salute è diritto di
ognuno è diritto di chi arriva e diritto
dei cittadini che stanno in italia in
maniera tale che siano sicuri che non ci
siano infezioni che possano arrivare
indisturbate le persone che hanno
necessità vengono ospedalizzate
tutti vengono rifocillati vengono
informati sui loro diritti
eppure questo è quello che accade ogni
giorno ogni notte anche in questi
momenti non è quello che basta non è ciò
che serve soltanto serve sia garantire
la dignità degli uomini e delle donne
che arrivano ma non serve a stabilire a
creare un futuro migliore per tutti
perché perché in realtà quello che manca
alla nostra politica migratoria alle
politiche migratorie europee e proprio
un'idea è un'idea nuova
cambiare è vedere che le migrazioni in
italia in europa e in tutto il mondo
possono realmente essere un'opportunità
come
anzitutto tramite dei corridoi umanitari
che andrebbero immediatamente a testi
con le zone in guerra dove ci sono
guerre dove non è possibile per gli
uomini e le donne continuare a vivere
occorre immediatamente aprire dei
corridoi umanitari e salvare le vite ma
non solo occorre anche capire fare
un'analisi dei bisogni nelle nostre
società nelle nostre comunità locali e
nazionali
abbiamo necessità abbiamo necessità di
nuove risorse di nuove menti e questo lo
possiamo fare lo fosse lo riusciamo a
vedere possiamo anche favorire una
migrazione adeguata a quello che è il
nostro contesto sociale
ma c'è di più quello che abbiamo il
dovere di fare quello che gli stati
hanno il dovere di fare e di sedersi
attorno a un tavolo in maniera seria e
favorire alle o ng a tutte le
organizzazioni che possono in questo
senso possono in questo senso lavorare
favorire dei reali progetti di
cooperazione allo sviluppo mentre noi
possiamo importare due forze nuove nuove
idee perché le nuove persone che
arrivano sono sicuramente nuove idee
pure noi possiamo esportare le nostre e
possiamo far sì che gli stati da cui le
migrazioni sono in questo momento una un
fenomeno di sola uscita possono
diventare invece stati e garantiscano un
opportunità intendiamoci nessuno lascia
il suo stato a casa sua se non è
obbligato a farlo salvo che per piacere
ma non è questo il caso abbiamo avuto lo
abbiamo visto tante storie ai moli
abbiamo visto anche quella di un
avvocato siriano con la famiglia che
aveva messo i suoi pochi averi e i suoi
documenti dentro un fazzoletto lasciava
la sua casa e sperava un giorno e spera
un giorno di costruire un futuro
migliore
per i suoi figli e non credo che quel si
diano voleva scappare dalla sua terra e
non esercitare la sua professione far sì
che nei paesi di origine possano essere
create delle opportunità sicuramente è
dovuto rispetto alla dignità delle
persone ma vi dirò di più è dovuto anche
rispetto al nostro benessere
pensate che cosa succede a stare in una
città in cui io abito nel più bel
quartiere ricco pieno di servizi però se
faccio cento metri più avanti
ho paura perché un quartiere dove non ci
sono controlli dove c'è violenza come si
sta in un mondo in cui stiamo bene o
cerchiamo di stare bene dei nostri
confini nazionali
quando a un tiro di schioppo ci sono
guerre c'è sofferenza c'è violenza
questo è quello che ci serve allargare i
nostri confini e non solo in senso
geografico ma anche in senso mentale
occorre superare il concetto di
beneficenza e occorre arrivare a un
concetto di cooperazione molto più ampio
fare l'interesse dei cittadini in questo
momento non è fare gli interessi degli
stati nazionali ma è cercare di fare
l'interesse dell'umanità intera